I thought that you just wanted to runs I
don't think we can never be just friends
[Applause]
how did you guys keep that chemistry
because it's just so clear on-screen we
always say no yeah I think it was good
costing yes yeah yeah we really got
really lucky with that because they
didn't have chemistry reeds together
they both had them with other people and
their chemistry too literally carries
the whole film
[Music]
was talked about scenes guys
the lake scene it is steamy AF like
legit it's it's just one of those things
I'm like okay you can't look away but
you should look away I mean can you talk
to me about filming that one were there
any behind-the-scenes secrets that we
would want to know about this steamy
night there was a snake story where
basically we found there was a snake
that was uh there's like a fish swimming
through the water upside down and over
see everyone's thinking that's not how
fish swim comes closer to the bank and
it's just like a huge metre long snake
fish in his mouth and the snake lady
whose name I forgot just kick yeah just
came and she had tools to pick up snakes
and just drop the tools and then her
hand just pulled out this name and I was
there like picking my jaw up off this
look because you don't really get that
in London but yeah when she picked up I
was like don't tell Joe because I just
kind of assumed that you wouldn't want
to know there's a snake in water that we
get into she's Australian so she's kind
of used to it although you are scared of
all the water bugs there's a difference
between a cockroach and a fly and
something that's like a lock then like
one you're not just things that like I
didn't know that they're like getting to
food and they can get into clothes and
like a golf balls well yeah but it could
like still cool into yeah well anyway
she's not scared of snakes right that
didn't matter but that was cool I feel
like after after you guys are going to
be the most talked about heartthrobs
like this is one of those movies that we
need for the summer but I want to get
your take on when you first found out
that this is going to be an adaptation
of a Harry Styles fan fiction what was
your reaction to landing this role my
agent told me that I didn't get at first
well you took me to knock we went to
like a cafe and sat down
couple things he was unfortunately cover
caught it now you never might be had to
say that and then he said that did start
just oh you Sonny tricked you yeah yeah
but no after that my settle down eyes
obviously over the moon oh I had a few
meetings and stuff before I got the call
that I officially got the wrong so I
felt like I sort of knew it was gonna
happen before date nothing could ever
change the way that I feel about you
well let's go ahead and talk about first
because obviously this touches on a lot
of further these are like 20-somethings
going off to college and they're really
exploring just like how life changes
more tests when she goes on to college
can you talk about how you relate to
those experiences and and maybe your
first heartbreaks that you've
experienced I don't I don't have an
experience that's you know too similar
to similar to that so I don't really
know but I feel like I drew more on
experiences that I've seen my friends go
through and people that I know go
through similar similar experiences and
drew from that yeah I mean I'm the same
I couldn't I couldn't honestly relate to
going off to an American College and
meeting a charming British boy and fully
loved but I think it was just stuff that
my friends have voluntary that talk just
about the the friendships and the
dynamics you guys have grown on set
because it seems like you all have
bonded really well yeah we were very
lucky that I think all of the cast just
everyone gets along so honestly and
genuinely we're all the same age which
is great because if you like a lot of
films people probably say yeah Carson
Cruz great well we all get on but like
genuinely everyone involved in this
stack we are going to see again and and
having that college-age experience I
mean you guys had a lot of fun it looks
like ya know some scenes which were
pretty fun yeah yeah we're doing it just
the ones where all the cars was together
it was like
yeah where we got a bonfire one way it
was like the true foot dancing yeah just
anything where we were all together now
you know everyone after they see this
they're gonna want to know what's the
next one the next installment has Anna
talk to you guys about that where we go
for it well if people watch this movie
we'll get a second one so we don't know
yet yeah we was pretty mean later we'll
see we're not sure yeah
[Music]